thank you so much professor it's a true
honor to be here with you guys today I'm
excited for all the folks watching
online as well as you mentioned I my
name is Josh I'm the CEO co-founder of
gusto and I have a cool fact to share I
actually took this class about let's see
12 years ago I was an undergrad master's
student in electrical engineering at
Stanford did signal processing and
another fun fact the three co-founders
of gussto were all electrical
engineering from Stanford and we're all
technically PhD dropouts from the EE
program here so here in the program stay
in it if not things will work out if you
decide to leave but what I wanted to do
today was kind of go through a couple
chapters of my life my journey hopefully
shares some advice that's constructive
to everyone here the the quick summary
on gussto though is we're a company
today about 400 people based in San
Francisco and Denver we serve over
40,000 companies today across the US
with what we offer which is payroll
health insurance HR and we have
investors that we're really proud of the
founders of Instagram PayPal Yelp
Evernote Eventbrite etc come on in
so like I said goal here is to be pretty
interactive if you guys want to jump in
ask questions during as well endure at
the end we can do either but we're gonna
basically go through kind of three
different arcs
it'll be really focused around a little
bit about me I've always found when I
was a student in these classes sometimes
people just dive into company or
professional work it's a lot more
interesting if you can get a bit of a
connection to the individual and see the
connections see the similarity is
probably more than the differences in
our backgrounds but then I'll talk about
my time here at Stanford and also
obviously what we're up to at gussto
more importantly some of the lessons for
you guys assuming that you want to start
a company yourself in the future or
planning to join a startup so diving in
a little bit about me I was born and
raised in the Bay Area
one of the few locals so if you guys
have ever been up to Marin right across
the Golden Gate Bridge it's where I grew
up awesome place for hiking
if anyone
afterwards wants to get some hiking
advice I have some tips for you and this
is a picture of my family I've one
brother and yes our mother is about a
foot shorter than the two of us and my
dad all I can say there is that powerful
people come in small packages
but the other thing I would add on on
family and background my parents are
both the first in their families to go
to college my mom is actually an
immigrant came to the US when she was 18
from Bolivia and my dad is actually from
a small steel town outside of Pittsburgh
his whole family had grown up working in
the steel factories and brick factories
there so we're gonna talk a lot about
entrepreneurship tech startups but my
definition of entrepreneurship is not
just about tech startups it's actually
much more about a mindset where you want
to change the way your life works change
the way the world works in some way my
mother moving to a whole new country
learning a whole new language putting
herself through school to me is a great
example of entrepreneurship which I
think we can all draw inspiration from
so it gives you a little bit about my
family my childhood
jumping photos are just fun so I thought
I'd put up for jumping photo hopefully
everyone here has done a jumping photo
at some point in their life I highly
recommend it but a big part of my
childhood was two things Boy Scouts my
brother and I are both Eagle Scouts so a
chance to really appreciate and enjoy
the outdoors which is again one of the
beautiful aspects of being in the Bay
Area and then also crew and I've
actually given some talks before where I
talk about crew which is rowing as a
great metaphor for leadership we would
row in eight person boats so four on
each side I was starboard it's about a
two thousand meter race it's over in
less than six minutes and the way it
connects to leadership and management is
you have this individual action you have
to do which is to pull in an oar it's a
very basic action it's very personal you
want to just pull it as hard as you can
as fast as you can
but then you have the balance in the
boat right so you're literally like an
inch off the water and you have four
people on each side and you're trying to
figure out how to be in sync because if
you're not in sync you're basically
gonna be banging left and right and not
going anywhere and then you have a Coxon
who's there basically helping the guide
direct
but they can't make you do anything
literally they're just there talking
right but done right they actually are a
big part of your inspiration they're a
big part of how you work together in a
common direction so you see the
connection to team building but for me
it was just fun to compete and try to
win races and that takes me to Stanford
my parents are both teachers actually my
dad taught in high school in San
Francisco Unified for a good 20 plus
years but much more on the English
history social studies side of the house
my mom was Spanish and French teacher so
I didn't really have any exposure to
technology per se growing up but I was
always interested in software and
interested in how things worked but
Stanford was really I would say the
first deep dive into what we now call
tech startups and so I came to Stanford
in 2001 it was right after the bubble
had burst so a unique time to come to
campus I think between oh one and oh
three there was actually a 40% decline
in enrollment in the CS major is what I
was told I'm pretty sure that's been
corrected given what I've heard about CS
and EE enrollment at Stanford today but
it was a really unique time and for me
at least it was a chance to I did EE I
did signal-processing dive into topics I
was interested in exploring I think
there's anyone doing engineering a
slight masochistic tendencies you got to
love being in basements we were talking
about that during our lunch the chance
to go do research and try to challenge
yourself and what you learn and what you
understand but for me it was great to
combine hiking in the outdoors as you
guys know Stanford has some great places
to go explore with for the first time
learning about engineering and learning
about what it meant to be in a more
academic structured environment I
actually was going to do a PhD in neural
prosthetics which you could think of as
probably not super related to payroll
software and HR software so there isn't
any huge connection there to me it was
more about trying to discover and learn
how the brain works I think one of the
most interesting complex systems that we
still have a lot of learning to do today
around and my advice for you guys I was
going to ask you actually how many folks
here are under
raise your hand a lot of undergrad and
then how many are in School of
Engineering hopefully that's everyone
cool so when I was an undergrad I think
there's an easy dynamic to get caught up
in I'm like what is the exciting thing
to do what is the exciting project to
work on it's really my penny more about
exploring like every summer I did an
internship in a different location I
worked at Intel for a summer I worked in
finance for a summer I worked in VC for
a summer I worked in a software company
for a summer I worked in different labs
each year it's about exploring and
discovering by the time I was about
ready to graduate you have to choose
though so I chose not to do the PhD
although it's a really interesting
program and chose to dive deeper into
building products what I think that
balance that choice you make is a deeply
personal choice and above all just don't
think of it as what is the right or
wrong choice there is no right or wrong
choice it's simply what you think is
most interesting for you and it takes a
lot more introspection to figure out
what that looks like my first job out of
school was at a company called Zazzle I
worked there as a product manager what
dreaming Azazel was really the chance to
build software but also work with a
really great group of people they had
just raised the series a it was about a
10 20 person team and I was a p.m.
they're helping to enable people all
over the world and make a living
creating products that they loved but I
was there for about three years I would
say was probably the first deeper four
way for me into how to go build software
in a professional way where you have
deadlines deliverables multiple
engineers involved and again a different
language than a school project and a
chance for me to get exposure to really
smart people while I knew at some point
I would probably go be doing my own
thing afterwards and that leads me to
the chapter before Augusto what I found
really interesting with the Zazzle
experience it was between oh five and
2008 we were growing very quickly we got
up to about 150 people and I actually
was doing my Master's on campus part
time so we're talking about this as well
during lunch
if some of you ever want to create that
loophole I did a code term seven classes
left one class a quarter for three more
years while working full-time it's kind
of a nice way to get best of both worlds
but I was in a class in 2008 that now is
called the Facebook class and it was
right when Facebook platform was
launching and this was back when people
didn't know that Facebook could become
something everyone uses everywhere and
so my friend and I who were
undergraduate classmates started a
company but I described this chapter as
a reactive chapter not a proactive
chapter because we just started building
stuff and we had a way for businesses to
build apps on Facebook we had millions
of users we actually had thousands of
dollars a day and ad revenue really only
a few weeks into the project and we're
you know thought that meant we were
being successful right I mean it's
supposed to be successful to have
revenue and and people using your
service but what was really confusing to
us was we didn't really feel like we had
a company and after two years we sold
that business because in retrospect we
realized we weren't really sure what
problem we were fixing right it was
almost more of an optimization of how do
we make more ad revenue how do we get
more users versus like what are we
actually fixing like what is the outcome
of this product on the customer what is
the thing that we actually are proud of
in terms of the impact we're having on
their life and so that way of saying it
I couldn't say when I was in that
chapter but if you guys are ever in an
experience like that you'll realize it
because basically you feel like you know
when someone asks you what you're doing
you're kind of like oh it's a stealth
project that usually means you don't
want to share because you're not proud
of what you're doing or you don't know
what it is that you're doing even right
ideally when you find something you
really care about and are really excited
about you're gonna be shouting it out to
the world constantly because it's
literally the thing you cannot stop
thinking about and smart Stanford
students can always figure out ways to
optimize systems optimize revenue
streams that doesn't mean it's a
business a business is more about fixing
something that you're truly truly
passionate about and connected to and
can't imagine not doing so we ended up
selling the business I would say it was
a important chapter in my life to figure
out kind of what matters in the context
of building a start-up not just having a
business for the sake of it
and so that led to a bunch of
introspection this is actually Palo Alto
foothills Park which is a beautiful spot
right across the 280 encourage folks to
go check it out if they haven't been
there but I used to go there every
Sunday actually and almost detach in
some ways and I think in the world we
live in today with smartphones it's
actually a little bit harder to do this
but even more important I would argue
all of you guys are in school right now
so you have quarters semesters as a
mechanism to figure out what classes you
like don't like what you want to keep
doing stop doing when you start working
you no longer have quarters and
semesters you just have life and if you
don't create a structure that actually
enables you to go choose when to revisit
what your projects are or decide what
you want to do next you could have 10
years passed by and you don't even know
if you wanted to keep doing what you're
doing so for me going into nature or
creating that forced time of
introspection actually was really
helpful to decide that that previous
chapter was no longer what I wanted to
focus on I wanted to try doing something
quite different and so that leads to a
little bit more of a story around gusto
actually was also gonna ask I mean how
many folks have been paid through gusto
we have one here that's good so we heard
that before but it's exciting to hear
obviously folks using the product
experiencing it we'll talk more about
the business and how we approach
building it but I wanted to start by
more talking about the people side of it
so these are actually my two co-founders
like I said we were all electrical
engineering at Stanford we Eddie and I
did undergrad together from a one Tomer
and I actually met when he came out for
his master's and PhD and what really
drew us together was much more of a
connection around core values and this
underlying desire to fix a problem we
had actually all had prior startups we
had all tried building businesses in
various ways learned from it and so when
we actually got together it was much
more of a discussion not just around
products businesses problems but
actually like what do you want to do
with your life what is your goal for the
next five 10 20 years and when we
realize we had a connection there in
terms of our underlying motivations for
why we
even care about tech and products and
startups that's what drew us together so
I put a photo here of my wedding
actually from two years ago because I
really do if you guys are considering it
think of founder relationships like
marriages and our wives call us work
husbands anyways so it's a relevant
metaphor either away but really above
all I think people get caught up in
thinking about we need to have a
business person in engineering person we
need to have as an alignment around what
you stand for as a person right and
that's a much much different
conversation than just pattern matching
on you know complementary skill sets per
se so our inspirations for starting
gussto as I mentioned we had this shared
value system how did we even get into
the market that were in how did we
become aware of this pain point well we
had all run prior startups so that was
definitely one of the inputs I had run
my prior business I had used a product I
wasn't very happy with so we all had
felt some of that frustration ourselves
and then these are pictures of our
families we actually realized that all
of us had exposure this is Eddie's
family his mom runs a small doctor's
office his dad's doctor's office and she
had done payroll and benefits by hand on
the kitchen table for a good 20 25 years
and he didn't think that made sense
Tomer in the middle his father owns a
small clothing store in Haifa Israel
it's a 1/2 person clothing store Tomer
had grown up working in the small
business he had also done a lot of
things by hand didn't think that made
sense and then this is my wife's family
my mother-in-law she runs payroll as
well and I had seen some of the
frustrations she went through in that
experience so when folks give you advice
think about a pain point you have you
know it's not just what you have as a
consumer pain point like we had all had
this pain point in building our
businesses building our products and had
some family exposure to that same pain
point and that's how we got into this
space right we definitely did not know a
lot about it ten years ago I would say
in the last five years we've learned
quite a bit about this market so that
leads to my piece of advice here around
kind of again there's many ways to build
a business many ways to think about
creating a company the one that I most
authentic to the one I most evangelize
falls into the bucket of a
mission-driven business but it's it's
not creating a business for the sake of
Augusto does not exist because I wanted
to exist right we're solving a problem
by building a business so it all starts
with a problem and if you start with
that is your origin point then you have
a bunch of considerations to make like
is it a big enough problem do enough
people get affected by it is what I'm
gonna create actually gonna fix the
problem or make the problem worse
perhaps right there's a lot of
corresponding questions to ask but at
the end of the day it all starts with
the problem and is it something that you
actually really feel like you could
spend years and years working on and so
for us there's two poor core parts of
the problem here I wanted to highlight
number one is just the sheer amount of
manual pain and unnecessary process that
a business goes through so that was not
just pain we had felt family had felt
but like every year a third of companies
in the US get fined for incorrectly
doing their payroll taxes and lots of
folks doing it on pen and paper so we
knew there was a lot of pain and then
and how did we learn that we talked to
lots of businesses right I think people
get cut up and staying in their rooms
and just wanting to go Google stuff to
figure out if there's a problem or not
we wouldn't talk to dozens and hundreds
of companies not just in the Bay Area
but went and called and talked to folks
across the country to figure out is
there a lot of folks feeling this pain
and we realized there was and then the
second problem is a little bit more if
you've seen the movie office space it's
a good movie from a while back but it
kind of is a caricature of how many
businesses are run as we spent more time
in the industry we came across
terminology like human capital
management Human Resources ADP is a
large company in our space called
automated data processing and we just
really got bothered by those
terminologies like people are not data
they're not capital and they're not
resources like they're human beings and
they should be treated that way and so
we had a very different point of view on
how the product could actually help you
build great teams right it's not just
about getting paid on time we're setting
up health insurance or creating a 401k
it's these life moments like how do you
feel when you join a company and when
you got that offer and your first day on
the job
and meeting your colleagues and do you
feel appreciated for your work and so a
lot of questions that I'm sure many of
you guys care about
in the companies you've worked at we
think every company ultimately can I
should care about so I'll share one
thing on gusto and then go back to more
lessons but this is our view of the
future we think that every company
everywhere will ultimately have people a
platform a course system that they use
whenever they want to build a team pay
that team and help that team do great
work that includes things from
industries like HR Payroll and benefits
but almost no one at gusto and we're
over 400 people now have ever really
worked in those industries we have
people when compliance for sure but most
of us approach it more from first
principles thinking about really what is
the right experience here what would an
employer prefer to have what would an
employee prefer to have and that leads
to a very different set of ideas and
thoughts versus just looking at the
existing landscape and so that concept
here of work and life I think many of
you guys probably think about quite a
bit as you're contemplating entering the
workforce I've always believed we've
always believed that work in life should
not be at odds with each other right you
know work empowers life life happens at
work it's not like it's a you know
professional you and a personal you
hopefully it's just you we see every
company again moving more and more in
that direction because that's what helps
you keep a great team otherwise people
will move on in and try to go to
different jobs and so our focus is on
bringing that to everyone today our
focus obviously is in the United States
so I think one of the lessons there is
actually to celebrate what you don't
know if we had spent a lot of time for
example working in this industry I think
you get caught up with a lot of legacy
knowledge you get caught up with how
it's been done before and then you end
up trying to build a better faster
cheaper version of what already exists
in reality it's actually kind of good to
just have that lack of knowledge because
then you can challenge those assumptions
you don't even know there is an
assumption you can just imagine what it
could be and then you know if someone
doesn't like it then obviously that's
probably not a good direction to go but
if you've now imagined it and it becomes
really valuable all of a sudden you've
had an insight or an innovation that
wasn't around before and one of the best
ways to think about this is imagining
back 125 years ago
you know people didn't want faster
horses that they wanted to move faster
so someone had to go and meant a car but
if you did a lot of research in the
industry and talked to everyone that was
involved in in horse breeding you would
have never gotten to a car you would
have simply gotten to faster horse
mechanisms right so you have to take
that leap of faith and in many ways
that's the benefit of being a first-time
entrepreneur or someone who has not
worked in an industry is you can
challenge those assumptions from day one
I mean for us it was as we talked to
people things like payroll and HR are
really seen as chores right they're
mostly seen as as chores hassles they're
seen as headaches or nightmares at times
depending on how much pain people go
through but for us we really thought
about it more as as these amazing
building blocks like we literally pay
people I walk around San Francisco with
my gussto shirt on and people are like
payroll guy right like literally we sent
an email every two weeks that says you
got paid today it's a pretty good email
to send a click-through rate and the
open rate is really high and so we
thought about these building blocks as
being really special like making sure
people feel appreciated for their work
helping employers show that appreciation
and so we just always thought that it
would be this thing people would really
connect to and care about but that was
never the way it worked in the past and
today with four years of being a live
company you know we've now reached over
40 thousand businesses with really high
customer satisfaction I would say we've
made some good progress improving that
thesis to be true the other piece of
advice I have is really more around I
guess the the pitfall here of taking
shortcuts you know again being born and
raised in Silicon Valley I see a couple
pitfalls here one is that people get
caught up in the echo chamber at times
and think about you know how do you get
somewhere faster can you cut corners
that can manifest in how you approach
finding financing you know fundraising
is is not the goal it's an enabler for
you to go achieve a goal but that means
that you shouldn't think about
fundraising as the thing to celebrate
it's it's building a sound business
along the way and I think it's looking
valley in the cycle as it goes ups and
downs through its ups and downs
sometimes forgets that message
another pitfall is around team like it's
great to hire people but the goal is not
to have a bigger team the goal is to
have more customers and be a sound
business a byproduct of that is the
ability to hire more people
so sometimes to meet founders and folks
talking about you know how much they've
raised or how big their team is like
those are good metrics but really what's
exciting is like do your customers love
your product and how many of them are
there right that's actually the core
metric everything else follows from that
and when folks see confuse they want to
go build bigger teams or raise lots of
money for the sake of it you start
getting lost on why does your business
exist in the first place and then that
third pitfall is really around
comparison I think it's easy to get
caught up in wanting to look at you were
someone else
ultimately you should really try to
compare yourself to what you think your
potential is and so in our business that
means we don't really talk a lot about
ATP or paychecks these are huge
companies where it's 40 and 20 billion
dollars but we didn't build those
companies we didn't build those products
right well we're building is gusto we're
building our products so our focus is on
talking to our customer serving them
well and then getting better constantly
and it actually avoids a lot of the
distraction that comes when you want to
you know either look at other company's
competitors talk about what's happening
talk is easy
what matters is serve the customer well
the other advice I have is related to
fundraising I've always seen it as
hiring so we have over 50 CEOs as
investors in gusto and we're really
proud to have these folks involved
they're amazing individuals we would
have probably honestly paid them to be
involved instead of them giving us money
so it's kind of a surreal dynamic but we
knew they got involved because they
wanted to fix this problem and so you
know for my example here like when I
think about VCS the average length of
time I've known a VC before I work with
them is actually over three years and my
favorite way to get to know them if you
know me a little bit now is to go hiking
so I go hiking with every investor and
try to figure out like who they are as a
person like what did they care about
what do they stand for what are their
core values like why do they go into
becoming a VC how do they measure a
success
I try to get to know them as a human
being because if we're gonna start
working together hopefully for years I
want to know them as a person not just
as a as a deal and I think a lot of
folks think of fundraising simply as a
financing event it is hiring right you
actually can't fire a VC so it's
part-time they're not with you all times
but they're they're on the team and you
want them to be there on your team so my
biggest advice on fundraising is think
about it as hiring and in our case that
means aligned values shared motivations
relevant skill set but a lot of folks
rush through that and just look at it
being as capital and then they regret it
afterwards um another thing here I also
love to spotlight and we have a couple
more left and then love to open it up to
Q&A is is this idea really around
community in a business and you know
it's fun for us to do photos and yeah we
have a good time together
we call ourselves guests ease it's it's
just a funny inside joke and if you guys
notice we also take our shoes off in the
office that's because we started the
company in a house in Palo Alto
we simply kept that tradition so today
in Denver in San Francisco everyone
walks around in socks it's pretty sweet
highly recommend it if you guys join
companies started companies it's a lot
more comfortable that way but and
there's a core message here where people
get caught up in thinking about a
business purely as just again product or
financials it's a group of people right
every business every organization is a
group of people coming together they
want to go fix something they want to go
solve something they have some
connection to each other and as a result
it's a community and if you want to go
support that community it means giving
them a chance through how you hire and
through the programs you do to connect
as people right and it's not rocket
science
we actually modeled it after college
right when did I most connect with
someone at Stanford
it was during dining hall like he was
just chatting with someone in the dining
hall so we have dining hall right and
it's the same table set up and we have
meals that's not very new in Silicon
Valley but I think people lost the
purpose behind that the purpose behind
that is just to have it be easy and
casual for folks to connect and chat
with each other the shoes off thing is a
bit more unique that's something that we
obviously like but not every company has
to adopt and then something else we've
evolved which we love to share with you
is something called gust away but it's
actually a retreat
we do and early on it was basically the
whole company just renting an air B&B
and living there for a week
and doing a hackathon and he was a
chance for us to organize into teams
choose different projects have a demo
day at the end of it each morning a
different group of people would be in
charge of cooking breakfast this worked
when we were about 10 people than about
20 then about 45 and then it no longer
fit in one house or two houses so we've
evolved it to gust away which is
actually us renting a Boy Scout camp for
a whole week folks going like a hundred
at a time for at least one night and no
one cooks there we don't people cook for
us but same spirit it's a chance for us
to spend some time in the woods connect
as teammates do some projects exercises
but also just have a good time so my
kind of biggest piece of advice I would
say and then I have one more a few as
students is if you're thinking of
starting a company there's a big
difference between wanting to start a
company for the sake of it or doing it
as something that you're so obsessed
about wanting to fix something that you
literally are forced into starting a
company to make it better and if you're
more in the latter camp a good way to
test that theory is to ask yourself
imagine this is the ten thousandth time
you're describing your business will you
be as excited and as sincerely
enthusiastic as the first time because
by that point you can't fake it it
either has to be authentic it has to be
natural or it's gonna be a chore and
that's worked really well for me my last
company did not have that dynamic and as
a result when we went through the
acquisition process it was the right
decision for that business because we
didn't really know what our purpose was
it was harder to build a team as a
result I couldn't evangelize because I
didn't really know what our due north
was with gusto I hope to be doing this
for many many decades to come I'd say
we've made some good progress in the
last four or five years but we have a
lot more to do but this is my millionth
time describing gusto and it's it's
always a privilege always an honor to
talk about it because I really care
about what I'm doing and you have to
find that in whatever makes sense for
you obviously it's your own business
your own project maybe your own
non-business activity maybe it's an
academia but think about what really you
enjoy doing and then use this rubric to
figure
it's something you can do for many years
to come and so my like biggest advice
piece of here for students is actually
related to this idea I think we were
talking about it at lunch of you know
FOMO has a popular way to put it these
days
a lot of behaviors a lot of tendencies
being driven by this fear of missing out
this what is the popular way to do it
what is the natural thing to do right
now actually starting a company is a
popular thing to do and that means
probably many folks should not start
companies because doing something
because it's the thing to do is actually
probably the fastest way to become
really unhappy and frustrated with it
because eventually you'll realize that
there are no grades in life right like
when you're in school there are grades
you have a very clear sign of hopefully
a success or failure in life there are
no grades and so all of a sudden you're
now figuring out like what is happiness
for me what is my journey and if you
don't take time to again detach from
that take some time for introspection
challenge yourself be uncomfortable
you're going to end up doing something
that perhaps you don't like and there
are some tracks that definitely have
more structure and one point I wanted to
be a medical doctor that has a lot more
structure with a lot more coursework but
if you end up choosing the
entrepreneurial path realize that it is
deeply a personal journey there is no
definition of success beyond like
hopefully it being something you want to
do for a long long time so I'm summery
on three pieces of advice here it's
definitely as much as you can take time
for introspection remember that in
school that's there automatically but
afterwards it goes away so create
monthly a quarterly and annual process
to figure out how you want to spend your
time and for me works really well to do
that in nature or to do that through
travel it was the inspiration augusto
for one of our kind of benefits everyone
in the company on their one-year
anniversary gets a free plane ticket
anywhere in the world and it expires on
the second year anniversary and that's
because we've always thought of I've
always thought of travel is a great way
to detach and figure out how I want to
spend my time and so we thought that'd
be a cool way to have everyone else
benefit around that same concept of take
time for introspection but again feel
free to feel free to bring that into
your companies if you want
that's not one that we
want to keep only ourselves it works
really well for us but might not work
well for everyone
second one is that there are no
shortcuts you know I think you're all in
engineering that means you have a
masochistic tendency in some ways that's
good that means you like being
challenged you like learning like you
know confronting obstacles and
overcoming them that's the best way to
learn I mean the most learning I've ever
done is when I'm in a position where I
have to do it I take on the
responsibility I used to run our sales
teams I used to run our marketing teams
I surround our finance teams our legal
teams by doing that I learned a lot in
that process have now hired some amazing
folks but don't shy away from that it's
it's one of the best ways to learn and
then three is the the main concept here
of imagine that ten thousandth time
describing your journey what you're up
to what your focus is and imagine will
you be as excited and as enthusiastic as
the first time you're doing it so those
were kind of some of the main advice
points and thoughts ideas I wanted to
share with you guys today happy to open
it up to QA on any of these topics or
anything else on your guy's mind yeah
yes so I think the the fastest way to
learn something if you're now put into a
position where you have to accomplish it
is by and this isn't rocket science but
there's there's reading so there's
various books publications literature
but probably the best way I've learned
is through talking to folks and you have
alumni networks that you can tap into
friends of friends networks but when I
was and I'm today you know hiring for a
CFO I wouldn't talk to a ton of CFOs and
I want to figure out what do they do how
they spend their time what are their
challenges were their obstacles what are
their priorities how do they make
decisions and I wouldn't say I today I'm
probably gonna be a great CFO on my own
but I know that I actually now have a
lot more knowledge on how that function
works and how those teams get their job
done so just basically don't lock
yourself in a room which I guess is the
tendency these days go out and talk to
folks and I always find that interaction
where you just ask why it's actually one
of our primary interview mechanisms but
literally when someone gives you an
answer like listen to it and then ask
why and then they give you another
answer and then just say why again it's
kind of like channeling your inner
four-year-old but it's actually a great
way to like peel back layers of an onion
and the way my brain works it's a very
structured way of thinking I like to
deconstruct problems simplify them
figure out the key moving pieces so it's
actually signal processing
it's just apply it not in a math context
it's apply now to like how business is
run how the economy functions
you know how market forms but to me it's
the same exact thought process yeah more
questions yeah more ideas I'd say we had
I had problems spaces but they're more
philosophical I'm happy to share those
with you but we pretty quickly got
excited about gusto and again for us
it's about the way a business has built
how teams are formed you know how you do
all these complex behind-the-scenes
things in software and we just we just
fell in love with that because we saw
how much opportunity there was but the
framework I had was was really thinking
about what had been missing in my last
startup actually I had had a startup in
college there was a non-profit and I had
this juxtaposition between the two
because remember my
my last chapter my last startup I had
kind of we've been building it we had
thousands of dollars a day and ad
revenue but something was clearly
missing whereas with the nonprofit I was
doing it from like midnight to 4:00 a.m.
for two years I wasn't getting paid
because there's a non profit but it
definitely did not feel like a job it
feel like a purpose and so what I
concluded was it's the problem so for me
the three problems that I will always be
most excited about either they connected
gusto or some of the angel investments
I've made are number one like businesses
that are involved in helping someone
make a living doing something they love
doing so that's an abstract concept but
that's what I loved about Zazzle was you
could actually be an artist anywhere in
the world
go put a product into the marketplace
and then make a living by actually other
people buying it and there's other
marketplaces like that obviously today
in effect but this idea of enabling
folks to follow their passions follow
their dreams and be able to get paid for
it and actually have that become not
just their hobby but also their
professional career really excited me
the second one was problems businesses
that are involved in helping people do
something they always wanted to do
there's something there about
empowerment that's really amazing I
think a lot of what technology does in
the world today is take things that only
a certain sub-segment of folks were able
to do either because of status or
because of economic resource and
basically drop it to become much much
more accessible for others and then the
third one is businesses that bring
massive time savings cost savings
efficiency to the world and in that
third bucket you can almost take any
category and b2b software almost any
industry one of my friends company is
called flex port is doing import-export
making it simpler easier for you to go
move products between countries all
these different industries have really
archaic software systems are massive
massive industries so maybe that gives
you as a framework some ideas but in
terms of how they apply to you I would
say think about also really what
problems you connect with it is a very
personal choice yeah yeah
but I close today day one you had your
first software you have to sell it yes
how in the world can you sell your first
one yes so our first 10 customers on
gusto were actually friends companies
but then once we were ready to launch we
actually didn't launch publicly for over
a year and that's because in our market
there are definitely no shortcuts we're
doing very mission critical things today
we move tens of billions of dollars to
the system we do hundreds of millions of
forms and filings and so we waited a
year launched publicly put up a website
and then PR was actually one of our
biggest ways to drive traffic
so it's organic word-of-mouth has been
our biggest growth driver we don't have
a very high touch outbound sales team
we're not knocking on people's doors
we're serving small business today so
our focus is primarily companies one to
150 employees and the beauty is that
people's behaviors have changed in that
way so 20 years ago you would have never
sold software to small business because
they don't pay you enough for you to go
send someone to knock on their door but
today that small business owner is on
google searching they're looking at
review websites they're on social media
looking at what their friends recommend
so they're not actually wanting someone
to go push it to them they actually want
to go discover it themselves and so we
can leverage things like Google Facebook
etc word-of-mouth to actually drive
quite a bit of attention and interest
folks sign up on our website and then
they convert to becoming a customer so
they have to pay to try your stuff out
yes we have a subscription business it
costs $39 a month per company and then
$6 per employee per month so as the size
of your company grows we make additional
revenue but that's because we're doing
more work for you and we give folks one
month free trial and over a 98% convert
from the free trial to paid makes sense
because once you're using the products
we're already now serving you and so you
just continue to stay with it over time
one thing I would add actually on a
technology trend that maybe you guys can
leverage as well our product really
would not have been possible to build 10
years ago and it's because the
technologies were leveraging weren't
around really and the behaviors were not
right so when you
on board Augusto you're giving us very
sensitive information your EIN your SSN
your bank number is your routing numbers
your family data your corporate data and
then you know ten days later we're
pulling twenty thousand dollars from
your bank account automatically right so
ten years ago people would never have
done that in a web browser but today
people are much more comfortable and
familiar with cloud-based technology we
didn't have to go communicate and
educate folks on that we can simply
benefit from that trend and same thing
with mobile many of these small business
owners don't have corporate offices
they're on the go and so you know they
weren't going to go home late at night
and install some payroll software onto
their family computer what happens
playing a video game at 10:00 p.m. right
they're gonna do it by hand manually
that was better but now with everyone
having a computer in their pocket we can
actually help them in a way that was
never possible before so whenever you're
looking at a market or a technology
trend you want to see if there's
something happening that actually
creates a big behavior shift and then a
whole new market can open up as a result
this market we're focused on has been in
pain for a long long time we felt like
now is the right time for it to be fixed
finally and I'd say we've made some good
progress but it's it's awesome for small
business owners these are incredible
folks I'm actually going to be doing a
road trip coast-to-coast in April
driving an RV to go meet small
businesses for ten days across the
country and it's really fun because it's
very different stories very different
types of companies bakeries flower shops
cafes churches hotels and in a represent
a huge part of not just the economy in
America but also the economy around the
world and then people who subscribe do
do they talk to you or is it more or
less all self done online and you never
deal with them directly so I think this
is also a pitfall in Silicon Valley at
times is thinking that somehow it needs
to be all software or no software you
want to just be very pragmatic about it
so for us all of the tax filings all the
payments all the insurance enrollment we
do in software because software is way
better than people at filling out forms
it's a very binary process I use the
analogy when you send a message to
someone in Gmail you don't have to know
how
SMTP and IMAP work to send them a
message same thing you should not have
to know how all these rules work to go
hire someone but if they have a question
they can call us they can chat with us
they can email us and we're always going
to be there to give them help so much of
it is DIY but if someone does have a
question we give them an amazing
experience and then as soon as that call
ends we try to figure out how to prevent
it from happening ever again
a roy scroll voice chat email whatever
you want will enable you to talk to us
but having like did your work yeah I
would say there's there's two thoughts
there
I'll reaffirm my my core message that
there is no one path it I think that's
the fun part of when I was transitioning
from student life to work life is
realizing because in school we're all
trained and educated to have a clear
path to define success it's getting into
a good school you guys got into Stanford
congratulations
getting good grades it's getting into
the next level of the program but again
like all that goes away you can make up
whatever structure you want after school
to define your happiness in life so for
me everything I've done has informed in
some way the way I operate Zazzle
absolutely informed it I decided to join
Zazzle out of school because I really
wanted to learn how to go build software
in a professional context and up to that
point I had mostly done hobby projects
so definitely it helped me but augusto
working on the product engineering side
has not been my focus my two co-founders
have been the ones to really lead those
efforts I definitely love having more of
a product bias because that's a part of
my DNA but much of my time has been
spent more on running our sales and
marketing teams so I would say like
above all again know that there is no
right or wrong way to do it each
experience you have can be a learning
experience now if your goal is to keep
building out different skill sets that's
healthy and definitely if one is like
how to go build software in a modern way
joining a company that's fast grow
probably post series-a out of school
where they can attract really great
people is a really really nice sweet
spot the reason for that is is the
growth piece of it whenever a company is
growing quickly new jobs are created
change is happening and as a result you
have a chance to keep growing with that
company very very quickly
so whenever folks ask me for advice on
jobs out of school I always say two
things one growth will find a company
and if you knew exactly which company is
gonna grow fastest you should be a VC
and then obviously there's a little bit
of trickiness there but you can look at
the best VC firms the companies they've
backed you know then being in a specific
size for the next five years will be a
really interesting chapter in terms of
new roles and new functions and new
projects being created and then to is
the values of the team like you become
like the people you spend time with no
matter what whether you want to or not
so really in the process of getting to
know a company figure out do they share
your philosophy do you want to become
like them do you like the way they think
are you aligned with it because you
would ideally work at a place that is
where you want to become more like in
the future QuickBooks has been out there
for a long time lots of small companies
use QuickBooks is yours a payroll system
that works with QuickBooks or or how how
does that all work yes so the question
was around software called QuickBooks so
the way we think about it is you have a
really important part of your business
that's the finance part of your business
and then you have the people part of
your business we're very focused on the
people part of the business so we don't
do accounting software we don't do
bookkeeping software our focus is on how
do you build your team how do you go pay
them how do you stay compliant but it's
all around the people side of your
company
so we partner with QuickBooks and Intuit
pretty closely and a lot of our
customers end up using gussto plus
QuickBooks
any more questions
yeah and I would forgot the name because
I know in history called Zed yeah yes so
we used to be known as then payroll as
you mentioned and yeah it's a funny /
very short story we we actually only had
a few days to choose the names and
payroll and it cost us $7 on godaddy and
so we chose it but it was all has a
temporary name and that's because we
knew that it was a limiting name it has
some existing words like payroll in it
and again most people would guessed oh
don't come from this industry we really
don't agree with the existing
definitions we think about it as a very
different view of what the future can
look like and so we knew we were gonna
change you we just had to find the right
time to change it and so we did it when
we launched a lot of our benefits
offerings my advice on naming in general
is to think about it really as a vessel
it's definitely not the only thing that
matters but it's one thing that does
matter but if you think about it as a
vessel
you know you fill that vessel with
meaning by serving your customer well we
just wanted a better vessel and that's
what we made the name change from
zenpayroll to gusto and gusto for us is
all about this energy this enthusiasm
this passion people have when they are
doing work they really love they're good
at or when you're an entrepreneur
starting a company that's successful and
it works
you know that's gusto so we really hope
that gussto in the future is connected
to that vibrancy that enthusiasm
whereas imperil was a good name but
ultimately was more about just keeping
things running smoothly and we like the
passion side of it good question
should wrap up thank you very much
[Applause]
you